labor day always a key moment in any
presidential race was dominated by
coronavirus concerns democratic nominee
joe biden claims president trump uses
politics instead of science to guide the
federal government's response
the president meanwhile says his
opponent is questioning vaccine research
paul reed is at the white house for us
paula good morning to you
this is a high-stakes political
conversation what else is the president
saying here
good morning tony well yesterday may
have been a holiday for many americans
but both presidential candidates were
busy trying to rally their supporters
ahead of the november election
president trump yesterday held an event
not too far from where i'm standing here
on the north side of the white house
it was billed as a labor day press
conference but it sounded
a lot like a campaign rally
biden is a stupid person you know that
president trump used the white house
as a backdrop for an abbreviated version
of his standard campaign stump speech
biden and his very liberal running mate
the most liberal person in congress by
the way
is not a competent person he vilified
his opponents for expressing concern
about political pressure rushing the
development of a vaccine
it would have to be a credible source of
information
that talks about the the efficacy
and the and the reliability of whatever
he's talking about i will not take his
word for it they're going to make the
vaccine
into a negative but the president has
repeatedly tied the vaccine's timeline
to the election
we're going to have a vaccine very soon
maybe even
before a very special date you know what
date i'm talking about monday afternoon
joe biden said that the president had
politicized the process
but if scientists said a vaccine was
safe he would
take it if i could get a vaccine
tomorrow i'd do it
if it cost me the election i do it
meanwhile the president continued to
refute a report by the atlantic magazine
alleging he canceled a visit to an
american cemetery near paris in 2018
because he reportedly said the cemetery
was filled with losers
only an animal would say a thing like
that but the president went on to attack
military leaders
i'm not saying the military is in love
with me the soldiers are
the top people in the pentagon probably
aren't because they want to
do nothing but fight wars so that all of
those wonderful companies that make the
bombs and make the planes and make
everything else stay happy
and biden seized on the report invoking
his late son beau
an iraq war veteran who died of cancer
in 2015.
when it comes to veterans he's downright
un-american i've never said that about a
president ever ever ever
these are heroes i'll tell you something
my beau wasn't a loser president trump
heads to florida
and then north carolina later today one
of the top republicans
in the county that the president is
visiting in north carolina
is encouraging the president to wear a
mask during his visit and follow the
governor's order
he advises the president that when in
rome do as the romans do
and when in north carolina do as the
governor says
now just a moment ago i got off the
phone with a white house source
who tells me that the president is
currently working on a list
a potential supreme court pick so those
are people that he would nominate to the
high court
if he got an opening which is very
likely if he's re-elected
i'm told that that list could be
released as soon as this week
anthony all right paula thank you